in the u.s. 84 percent of the people on
the waiting list need kidneys so kidneys
are by far the largest part of the organ
shortage 20 to 30 people die every day
we would be saving all those lives I am
Nicholas B with recent TV and today
we're talking with Z grid fried Revere
she's the author of the new book the
kidney cellars a journey of discovery in
Iran she's also the founder and
president of the center for ethical
solutions
Sigrid thanks for talking to us Thank
You Nick you go to Iran and one of the
most fascinating things about the book
and about your journey there is in
America we have waiting lists for people
who are trying to get kidneys there they
have people who are on a waiting list to
sell their kidneys you know how is the
kidney market working in Iran it's
pretty amazing because 30 years ago when
Iran had its revolution they were
actually part of the European network so
they were engaged and learning how to
use cadaver organs the way we were doing
it and they were you know going back and
forth with the technology and even with
the kidneys and when they got cut off
partially obviously due to their own
desire not to be part of the West and
because of sanctions they had to think
outside the box because their kidney
disease patients were dying so there you
have started with a 30 year history of
developing towards a system that works
and one of the things that just amazed
me is that if you had watched Iran or if
you you know learn about the history of
what they did you can see how they move
to more and more compensation more and
more benefits for donors more and more
security for donors and now you're up to
the point where donors get approximately
in u.s. equivalent forty five thousand
dollars worth of cash and services and
and this is for living donors because
they don't really most of us don't need
two kidneys so you essentially in Iran
you can sell a kidney and get forty five
thousand dollars back what kind of
impact has that had
you know there's a waiting list for
people to sell organs I assume that that
means people who need organs get them
pretty right quickly everyone who needs
an organ can start the process right
away the process takes longer than the
Iranians had claimed I mean it took
about 16 months for the people I
interviewed on average in the u.s. 84
percent of the people on the waiting
list need kidneys so kidneys are by far
the largest part of the organ shortage
20 to 30 people die every day we would
be fading all those lives so what has to
happen for you know this because this is
a mind shift for people to say okay
we're going to allow people to be
compensated for organs I mean we allow
people to be compensated for certain
types of blood products and you know in
other types of things as long as they're
replaceable right what has to happen
both in terms of legal changes as well
as kind of philosophical understandings
to to move forward into a different era
of organ compensation that's really an
excellent question and that's really the
hardest hurdle to come over and one
thing I learned in Iran is they don't
think of it as selling you know your
organ is not a commodity it's not a
widget that you can make more of what it
is is it's a service to humanity so what
the person is selling is a service it's
trying to help someone else it's not
they don't really think of it as giving
their organ away or selling their organ
and it's really interesting because we
talk about organ donation in those terms
and so I've started to talk about
compensated organ donation because every
single kidney seller I interviewed said
the money is important it's what allows
me to be altruistic without money I
can't do a good deed right so what you
know what has to happen like who are the
biggest people who are against the
compensated organ donation well really
it's kind of a fluke in history because
what happened is when the national organ
transplant Act was passed it was passed
to create a system for distributing
cadaver organs because we had really
just discovered with anti
I mean with immunosuppressant drugs
excuse me
that we could use cadaver organs and so
the thought was why but a human being at
risk at all
and so that fluke caused Congress to ban
all compensation is the idea of
self-ownership which seems central to
you know most libertarian ethics is that
on the rise and is it on the rise in a
way that affects medical treatments
where I own my body you know we see drug
legalization of various places and
people saying you know it's my body I
get to decide what goes into it are we
getting to a place where that will
ultimately transform medicine and saying
I or organ donation I get to do I get to
control what comes out of my body I wish
that were true unfortunately I don't
think so
because a lot of the ethicists want to
go in the direction of presumed consent
which is essentially eminent domain over
the body that when you die your body
belongs to the state as opposed to
yourself or your relatives and that is
troubling for any number of reasons but
partly because if presumed consented so
they could also say well you know is he
great you're like you're you're gonna be
dead sometime so I'm just gonna pay it
forward and take your organs now without
your consent because they're not really
yours anyway that's I mean theoretically
that's possible but that's a slippery
slope yeah that you know that's an
argument you could apply to almost
anything right so I'm not sure that
would happen but I think just the notion
that we should be giving away even our
body parts for the sake of the state is
really ridiculous and these things are
worth something and if I'm worth
something or part amis were something
whether it's my labor or my hair or my
eggs or my kidney and I'm willing to
give that to society I should be
compensated for that and for goodness
sake Society is willing to these
recipients are going out on the black
market and taking huge risks so there's
no doubt that people are willing to
compensate people for their organs
alright well we'll we will leave it
there we've been talking with Z grid Fri
Revere she's the author of the kidney
sellers a journey of discovery in Iran
which has gotten phenomenal reviews
Kirkus really loved it she's also the
president
Center for ethical solutions Sigrid
thanks so much for talking to recent TV
Thank You Nick for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie